the gyro can experience it's also
striking because you realize over the
course of the book and I mean just and
then more books that I've gotten into
subsequently that this was something
that was going on before the white
settlers even got there that this way of
life and the rating and the the killing
and that's not what we associate Native
Americans with we associate with us with
taking the Native Americans land and
then them fighting back and that's when
things get ugly
but it turns out this was just a wild
way of life that they had had for who
knows how many years one of the things
that surprised people when I wrote this
book and I didn't know that I was going
to be surprising people because I was
just reporting what I found was was was
that that very thing that that this was
I think people are often used to the
berry' my heart at Wounded Knee
narrative of the of Native Americans
which is as victims yeah and there's no
question that they were victims of a
westward rolling Empire and 378 broken
treaties and we can just go on we know
what that narrative is like but the
narrative that I told was a narrative
power of dominance of power which came
with brutality too and I think it
surprised it was a fact it was a fact
that that if you go back in time these
indeed these Native American tribes that
eventually got crushed as the Comanches
did and put on a reservation somewhere
and had their livelihood taken away from
them but you know it really anyway it's
a it's a it's a huge deal
and and a narrative that I think to me
that doesn't take into account the
enormous power and dominance and
behavior of Comanches is just missing
you know half the half the narrative
well it's so fascinating because it's
essentially they were living like Stone
Age people and they were doing it very
recently they were they were doing it
like in terms of the way Europe is you
could go and see buildings in Italy that
were built long before any of this stuff
happened long before the settlers
started encountering them and they were
live
like this and this sort of it's very
romantic
the the way they live just chasing the
Buffalo and three-way and killing them
and then eating only buffalo meat and
then doing very little farming and
picking some berries and nuts and that's
about it I mean it was just eating meat
and raiding and killing they were they
were hunter-gatherers yeah they were
nomadic hunter-gatherers yeah which is
what they were and and what the horse
allowed them to do was to which is what
they had been before the horse led them
to do that only just really really
really well in other words they were
they weren't in a position of becoming
agricultural Indians the horse gates and
this ability to and as you said that
they got everything from the Buffalo
clothing and and lodging and and tools
and saddles and bridles and food I mean
everything came from the Buffalo so the
horse just enabled them to do this an
incredibly sophisticated level it's the
most sad part of the story is the extra
painting of the Buffalo I mean that's
not the most sad but one of the that
their way of life it's almost like you
know what happened but I'm rooting for
them in some weird way you know I mean I
know that they're not going to win but
there's something about the way they
lived it seems so exciting
[Applause]